we take for granted that our mental
lives are private the mind is a safe
space to plan and imagine and dream
right well back in 2008 it was
impressive when a model could identify
among the set of images which one a
person was viewing during an fmri scan
but now a recent work has adapted modern
text to image models like stable
diffusion to reconstruct not just
identify images being viewed the
low-level details are not always correct
but much of the semantic content is
successfully captured now we know large
generative models are pretty data hungry
while brain scan data sets are
relatively small how do we get around
this a common approach is to leave the
pre-trained generative model as is the
only component actually trained on the
brain scans is a simple often linear
mapping which links the fmri activity to
a embedding provided as input to the
generative model it'll be interesting to
see if future models can decode not just
what someone's actively seeing but even
what they're thinking